die Leute hören das Wort Klimaschutz und
kriegen die Krise die haben Angst um
ihre Heizung Angst um ihre Wohnung Angst
um ihre Zukunft übrigens auch viele weil
sie sehen dass es Extremwetter
Ereignisse gibt und dass das Thema Klima
wirklich ein dringendes Thema ist aber
das ist in der Lebensrealität der
Menschen mittlerweile so das Klimaschutz
ein hass-thema geworden ist zu sagen ich
wollte keinen Klimaschutz oder die FDP
wollte kein Thema Schutz ist einfach
absolut daneben wir haben gerade das
Gebäude Energie gesetzt abgestimmt in
einer Weise wo wir massive Veränderungen
erreicht haben das stimmt und als
nächstes kommt das solarpaket und als
nächstes kommt das Thema Schutzgesetz
wir machen twenty Force 7 Klimaschutz ja
die FDP erreicht für den Klimaschutz
mehr als mancher Aktivist
[Musik]